hello everyone and welcome to 2022 uh
usually uh starting a new year is a
pretty serious business here on this
channel and we often like to
well not often but uh always uh for for
the past few years i decided to show a
crazy game where there's a brilliant
queen sacrifice and well that's
something that everyone enjoys myself
included uh but for this year i decided
to start the year as this is the first
video i'm making in 2022. uh sorry about
the board being weird i decided to do
something different uh it's um
it's a game from the 1942 united states
championship was played in new york uh
and it's played between carl pilnick and
samuel richevski needs no further
introduction we've had him on the
channel many times and well he's a
legend of american chess uh everyone
knows who hurrichewski is there there
isn't a player he hasn't faced he he had
his uh clashes with bobby fischer and
with many of the great chess players
of that era
but here carl pilnik even though this is
a very uh new photo of him uh he he died
sadly in 2013 i believe um
this was played when pilling was
18 or 19 years old i believe maybe maybe
19.
and it's it's a game that shows uh how
well you know when when things uh seem
really really bad and
there's just no way out like it has been
for for the past two years for many
people and opportunity presents itself
and well it is possible to seize this
opportunity so uh without further ado
let's check it out as
it's just a beautiful uh beautiful
ending to the game so pill nick with the
white pieces opens with d4 and pink was
um
a chess player for his entire life he
was also considered somewhat of a chess
prodigy but this is one of his i i
believe earlier tournaments because uh
he for example he won the united states
open championship in 1971 which is uh
was some 30 years after this game was
played so he was a a chess player pretty
much his entire life and uh
interestingly uh he only scored half a
point in this tournament uh which is
kind of a spoiler but it's not
really relevant uh whereas arashevsky
won the tournament although they say
that uh as it states in the in the
tournament database and aaron is ruling
by the director allowed reshevsky to tie
for first with isaac kashdan and then
they had a playoff and um
one but uh that's you know i just wanted
to mention that so let's check out the
game uh pill nick opens with the d4 we
have knight to f6 by the chevsky c for
g6 uh f3 uh and d5 uh going for the new
groomfield defense see captures on d5
knight captures on d5 and now e4 chasing
away the knight which is a bit different
from the groomfield defense in the
standard runefield there will be a
knight on c3 and you will eliminate this
knight but here you have to go back so
knight b6 we have knight to c3 bishop to
g7 and now bishop to e3 we have castles
and nowadays queen to d2 is the main
move in this
line which is very natural you want to
play bishop to h6 you want to eliminate
this bishop but here we have f4 also a
move that's very very common today
knight to c6 we have d5 now chasing away
the knight and now arashevsky brings the
knight back all the way to b8 and this
is still today considered the absolute
best move we have a4 preparing to chase
away the knight and now black strikes in
the center with e5 nowadays c6 is is the
way to go you want to start by
destroying white center but e5 also very
much playable
and the point being that uh uh white
should accept this for example
characters captures a knight f3 it's
kind of in the spirit of modern chess
you want to develop the knight with
tempo
but uh pilnik played a5 which is also
perfectly fine knight back to d7 and now
knight to f3 putting more pressure on e5
queen e7 developing the queen adding
more defense the e5 and now uh there is
a game where bishop to 82 was played
with bishop to d3 is the move uh well as
of move 13 this position has never been
reached again so let's see what happens
e captures on f4 we have bishop captures
and i straight here yeah and now knight
to e5 rushevsky plays very natural
principled moves he wanna he wants to
exchange some pieces as his opponent is
controlling a bit more space so knight
captures an e5 bishop captures with
bishop captures queen captures and now
felnic castles we have knight to d7 uh
black uh is playing a very nice game he
has a nicely centralized queen the
knight is coming probably to f6 then the
bishop will be developed and then the
rooks are also coming into the game
maybe the d8 and e8 maybe d8 and c it
all depends on what white plays so rook
to c1 and now queen to d4 with check
further infiltrating with the queen king
to h1 and now knight to e5 threatening
to pick up the bishop here bishop back
to e2 bilnik offers a queen trade and
arshevsky declines he plays queen to e3
for the moment you don't have to worry
it's very difficult to kick away this
queen the f3 square nicely guarded by
the knight so filny goes for knight to
b5 he wants to capture the c7 pawn as
it's now attacked by the rook and by the
knight but here just c6 kind of taunting
white to go knight c7 but if you do this
after rook to b8 the knight really
doesn't have any squares all of these
squares are
unavailable to the white knight and well
you just might leave it stranded there
so after c6 we have knight to d6 putting
pressure here on the
light square bishop rook to d8 now
asking what do you want to do with the
knight and first rook c3 chasing away
the queen from such an active square
queen to g5 and now only now knight
captures on c8 we have rook a captures
on c8 and now bishop to f3 so black
developed all of his pieces he doesn't
really have anything to worry about if
anything his position is slightly better
so here we have a6 uh and now queen to
b3 pilling goes after the undefended b7
pawn and roshewski just defends that
rook to c7 now he can double up on the c
file or on the d file depending on what
white plays
h3 uh creating some more breeding room
for the king also taking away the g4
square from the knight and rook c to d7
putting more pressure on the d5 pawn
rook to c5
this is now a bit unpleasant for black
because if the position opens up both
the knight and the queen are on the
fifth rank so uh he brings it back queen
to a7 and now queen to c3 defending the
rook on c5 we have knight captures on f3
rook captures an f3 you have to capture
with the rook otherwise this rook hangs
and now c captures on d5 we have e
captures on the e5 and the rook captures
and d5 rook captures with rook captures
and after all of this um uh well uh
captures have been made uh the position
is well black is up a pawn and white
doesn't really have all that much to
show for so he's gonna have to fight
very hard to save this game we have
queen to c8 check king to g7 and now
queen to c3 with check uh checking to
see if roshewski will maybe repeat the
position we have f6 of course rashford
wants to play on and now rook to d3
white says all right let's trade off uh
our last remaining pair of rooks and
let's play a queen and pawn end game you
are up upon it should be winning but
you're gonna have uh well a very hard
time uh proving that so rook captures
queen captures and now queen to e1 with
check we have king to h2 and now not
capturing on a5 if you capture on a5
then queen d7 check picks up the b7 pawn
and it's still very unclear so this way
you win a clean pawn queen e5 check king
back to
h1 and now we just pick up the a5 pawn
so now black is up two pawns and this is
now uh well this should be winning
however uh sorry not queen captures an
a5 queen captures on b2
capturing an a5 would be silly uh
because it runs into the same uh trap so
now you're up two pawns queen d7 check
white has to try and somehow gain some
sort of a perpetual king h6 we have
queen to d8 uh and now if the black
queen moves we can pick up the f6 pawn
but just queen e5 nicely centralizing we
can start pushing our pawns while our
pawns on the queen side are somewhat
protected uh and also we're attacking
the a5 pawn if the white queen moves so
queen d2 check with king queen to g5
blocking and now queen to d8 again we're
defending our a5 pawn queen to
f4 now and the queen to f8 with check so
now black needs to figure out a way how
to get away from all the checks and try
to make some progress in the position so
here king g5 we have queen to c5 check
queen to e5 again white can never trade
queens because the king and pawn end
game is winning for black so queen c1
check king to h5 now comes queen to d1
with king back to h6 queen d2 check
we're gonna block with the queen queen
g5 and now queen back to d8 and white
says uh you're not making any progress
so queen to c1 check king to h2 now
queen c3 defending our f6 pawn attacking
the a5 pawn and now adjust the king back
to h1 uh we have queen to e1 check why
it plays king h2 and now king to g5 so
again roshiwski has to try uh to get
those pawns on the king's side moving
somehow at queen to b6 and now as our
pawn is attacked we have to defend it
queen e5 check king to h1 now queen e7
we are defending our pawns queen to b1
now uh and king back to h6 we have queen
to c1 check king to g7 and now queen to
d2 white isn't able to give any more
checks so now black finally starts
advancing the king side pawn so we have
h5 queen to c3 and now g5 so little by
little archevsky making progress uh
queen to d2 now comes h4 we have queen
to c3 queen to d6 now uh queen to b3
attacking the b7 pawn queen c6 defending
we have queen to a3 now trying to
go for some back rank
uh checks king to f7 stopping this we
have queen b3 check king to e7 queen to
e3 check king d7 now the chefs shift the
king over to the queen side queen d3
check king to e6 queen to a3 and
knocking back to d7 we have queen to d3
check and now king to e6 we have queen
to d8 uh and king to f7 so natasha still
not sure on how to
proceed here uh king to h2 now king e6
we have king to h1 and now queen to d5
finally offering a queen trade queen c8
to check we have king to f7 queen to c7
check and now king to g6 so as you can
see this is perfectly normal with queen
and pawn in games if you're up upon you
will have to suffer many many checks
before you have a chance to prove that
your extra pawn is in fact winning so
queen to c to check f5 now finally we
have another pawn push and queen to a4
we have f4 now with uh finally with the
idea of f3 now this will bust open
white's king side and then you will also
be able to give some checks so queen to
e8 with chuck king to f6 now comes queen
to f8 check king to e6 and now queen to
e8 checking to d6 queen f8 check king to
c6 and now queen back to a3
uh and now queen to d2 so what do you
play here well queen tay for check white
has doesn't have anything better you
have to continue checking king c7 and
now queen to a1 trying to maybe get
queen e5 check to pick up the g5 pawn so
queen e3 now preventing this and the
queen the g7 check with uh king to b8
and now uh queen to g8 to check
uh king the a7 and now queen to d5
interestingly if you grab the g5 pawn
queen to e5 e1 check wins by force king
h2 and then queen g3 check we just uh
trade down into a winning uh
pawn end game and this is of course
completely winning now for black so oh
you can't do that queen to d5 is played
now comes f3 finally uh even though
you're kind of giving up a pawn you
don't really care uh g captures on f3
and now queen to e1 check king to g2
queen g3 check king to f1 and now queen
captures on h3 with check king g1 and
now queen to g3 check king h1 and now
queen to f2 now you already have some
checkmating ideas with h2 queen to g2
checkmate and you are guarding this
diagonal so that means white will never
be able to give a check but remember
this sentence very well as we are
guarding this diagonal white will never
be able to give a check to our king so
here that white plays f4
you have to do this otherwise you're not
going to be able to defend g2
queen to f1 check king h2 and now black
even captures the f4 pawn with check now
black is up three pawns which is of
course completely winning king h1 queen
to e3 again uh controlling this diagonal
and now queen to f5 seemingly useless uh
but uh there is more than meets the eye
here hendrich is in a completely winning
position pretty much every move you make
here is completely winning except the
one reshevsky made here reshevsky played
g4
and well it's just uh it's just a
terrible move to make so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
refutation of this g4 idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not picking up the
pawn and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show uh it's uh in fact
queen to f2 uh this is what pilnick
played and it was in this position that
pilnik and rushevsky agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more for black
to do here problem is uh
if you don't capture the queen white
will capture your queen you can't move
the queen uh otherwise your king will be
in check so even though
i think this is beautiful even though
you're controlling the only diagonal
white can use to deliver check uh white
does exactly that okay it's not
technically czech but you are preventing
the black queen from moving uh and here
they agreed to a draw because if the
white queen is captured then it's a
stalemate white king has no moves the
black queen controls all of three
squares uh and this is uh this is just
amazing how how pill nick got a draw
yeah here and how he's uh
what a sneaky guy he prepared it with
queen f5 uh it was the only chance uh
black hat g4 and then queen to f2 simply
amazing and i often see well not often
because i don't play in tournaments um
uh that often uh nowadays but uh
i i know some people that you know they
get a bad bad position and then they
just resign but you you always have to
fight until the very last moment and you
know look for opportunities like this
one here
like every move on the board was winning
like in any move you play it's still
winning you're up three pawns but this
one it's just uh i mean it's just said
for a chevsky uh but it's great for
peeling because it's the only uh half a
point he got in this tournament so uh he
didn't go into playoffs only he only
played three games maybe he played more
they say that not all the games are
available from this tournament but
what a half a point
to grab from uh from the winner of the
tournament samuel rashevsky and out of
all the games in this tournament i'm
pretty sure
this is the only one uh well most of you
will
will see
uh so congratulations to carl filnick on
this great great achievement and i
thought um it's a queen sacrifice
although it's not a queen sacrifice
black can accept or rather it's a queen
sacrifice black must accept in order to
avoid losing the game so i thought we'd
start off this year uh well with another
sort of queen sacrifice and that even if
you had a bad 2021 or even a bad 2020 or
both of them uh you know uh things can
really pick up all of a sudden like it
did for karl pelnek in this game
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
happy birthday keith friedland uh happy
birthday max diego janssen los melzwad
and constantinos matramatis for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day